[Music]
that's not what the book yeah it's your
Bald's next big thing yes what inspired
this children's book well I'm very
excited about this I've been an actor
for almost 20 years and I kind of I was
in a pad and I saw myself where every
time I'd get a good can I've had some
great gigs but every time I get a gig I
was still thinking about the next gig I
was never on that gig I was always
thinking what's next and I think you can
fall into a trap you get so focused on
the next adventure you miss the
adventure you're on oh it's about a
little chicken who's who's goes on the
all these great adventures but every
time he's on the adventure I gotta get
to my next big thing and is this little
companion that falls around with him a
bee who teaches them a very valuable
lesson and it's a I mean it's a lesson
that I'm still trying to learn but I'm
really excited about it I'm glad that
bees and chickens are getting along
thank you thank you I'm bringing it back
it's about time they set aside their
differences I was flipping through the
book and you get a really nice job with
this children's book and I think my kids
are too old but but I think this would
be a very nice book for for parents to
read to their children I noticed one
thing that might be a mistake which is
you have archibald is a chicken is he
not sitting here and push in on this
he's eating breakfast and he's eating
eggs
did you know did you know that they have
a chicken eating eggs or that isn't
getting their quote can you see guys he
likes his people yeah he's hitting the
lining of his wall cuz he's in the egg
that's raining no you should did you
know that I actually just learned that
fantastic
I'm really excited on it my baby Tony by
Agni wrote it with me and he's a great
dudes
alright are you what are you gonna do
you're gonna write a next you're gonna
write more children's book you're right
there on the present Conan yeah that's
like I'm the chicken in year the be just
be that's the lesson it's good right the
story away yeah yeah what don't you want
to sell book no I told them the ending
yeah you've told them the ending sorry
but you gotta be man says great that is
great I love it
yes you did break
it really changed a lot of minds today
oh my god this took a turn yeah it did
and I'm loving it it really is a sweet
book Archibald's next big thing is now
available on Amazon your kids will love
this Tony Hale your
[Applause]
you